monsieur philippe le ray merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de l'environnement de l'énergie
et de la mer madame la ministre
l'ostréiculture est une activité
importante sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
elle est créatrice de nombreux emplois
directs et prend toute sa part dans
l'économie touristique
malheureusement après un hiver plutôt
doux et quelques phénomènes de
contamination rien que dans le morbihan
près de 80 entreprises ont subi des
fermetures administratives
suite à la détection de la présence d'un
norovirus ce problème a eu lieu
également dans d'autres départements est
une question récurrente sur l'ensemble
dû littoral français pour la pêche à
pied professionnels et la
conchyliculture durant plusieurs mois
fort heureusement l'état a interdit
toute commercialisation des huîtres et
des coquillages en provenance des
différentes zones touchées mais
l'abrogation des arrêtés
la menace de contamination est toujours
présente en effet après autres virus les
professionnels craignent cette fois
l'arrivée potentielle de l'algue
dinophysis la fermeture même temporaire
de ces entreprises menacent la pérennité
de nombreux emplois et fragilise
l'activité économique d'une filière en
effet les professionnels subissent ces
interdictions pour des
dysfonctionnements ou des phénomènes
environnementaux dont ils sont pas
responsables c'est pourquoi ils
sollicitent la mise en place de
dispositifs dead de soutien ou de
garanties ne peuvent-ils pas bénéficier
d'une exonération de la redevance
d'occupation d'occupation du domaine
maritime
ne peuvent-ils pas bénéficier du fonds
national de gestion des risques
sanitaires
andry culture dont ils dépendent à
défaut et surtout pour rassurer les
jeunes qui souhaitent s'installer
pouvez-vous mettre en place un nouveau
fonds de garantie peut-être en
mobilisant le fonds européen pour les
affaires maritimes et de la pêche
je vous remercie monsieur le ré la
parole est à monsieur jean marie le guen
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le temps d r si monsieur le
président monsieur le député leur et la
préfecture vous le savez a levé le 22
avril l'interdiction de la pêche à pied
le commercialisation des huîtres sur la
rivière de crac'h
c'est une vraie satisfaction pour des
ostréiculteurs durement touchés d'autant
que cela fait suite à la levée de
l'interdiction qu'on subit les
ostréiculteurs de la ria d'etel il y a
quelques jours les fermetures pour ce
nouveau virus dans le morbihan était de
17 jours en 2010 15 en 2014 62 ans en
2016 et donc nous avons en tête les
questions de marché bien évidemment de
la soixantaine d'entreprises et près de
100 professionnels qui sont aujourd'hui
touchées le gouvernement est très
sensible à leurs problématiques et il
est donc dans l'action ils veulent
oeuvrer dans le temps long à la mise en
oeuvre de bonnes pratiques à la gestion
des eaux
la place réservée à cet enjeu dans la
conférence en virant nord mental était
d'ailleurs l'illustration de cet
engagement je crois notamment à
l'implication nécessaire des
collectivités dans leur mission
d'assainissement à la fois collectif
mais aussi non collectif le coordinateur
national sur ces questions sanitaires
réseau sanitaire aura bientôt dans le
morbihan je crois la semaine prochaine
où il pourra s'entretenir avec les
professionnels au delà de la
responsabilisation de tous nous
souhaitons que puisse dans le cadre
d'éventuelles fermetures à venir
améliorer encore un peu la réactivité de
tous les services de l'état au service
des professionnels qui sont dans ces
épreuves
c'est pourquoi nous pensons à
l'étalement des charges sociales et
fiscales aux questions touchant le
chômage partiel à l'incitation des
établissements bancaires à assurer leur
concours à des dispositifs assuranciels
à l'action des assurances des dessins
des assistantes sociales qui sont
dévoués à cette tâche
alain vidalies c'est stéphane le foll
sont donc tout à fait attentif à cette
situation et savent l'importance de
l'activité de cette activité pour le
littoral maritime
monsieur le guen la parole l'état